i'm so sorry it has just come to my
attention that i forgot to wish you all
a happy junty first
it it is junete first today we are
observing the holiday yesterday was june
20th
i also didn't mention june 20th and then
of course june 20th was the day that the
federal government has decided that we
would celebrate juneteenth which is now
a federal holiday it occurred the day
before on a sunday and so juneteenth was
observed on monday june 20th and we are
now discussing it here on tuesday june
21st
and if depending on how you react to
this segment i might be able to answer
more of your questions tomorrow on
june 2nd
june 2nd before june 23rd and june 24th
i know i know that republicans want to
embrace juneteenth there are many
republicans who are embracing juneteenth
you know that really sacred feast day
that no one had heard about until five
minutes ago when the libs invented it
and they want to republicans want to
embrace juneteenth
because one it's supposed to be about
freeing the slaves republican the
republican party freed the slaves
and two we just don't want to be called
racist we are called racist all the time
unjustly by the dems and it bothers us
even when we say that it doesn't bother
us and we want any opportunity to show
the libs that were actually democrats
are the real racists and we're not
racist and we but it's just
juneteenth is just
a bad idea
it's a dumb holiday
and the only point of juneteenth
is to
make slavery
to put slavery more at the center of the
american story to emphasize the role of
slavery in america and crucially to
emphasize the importance of the legacy
of slavery when crafting all of our
future policies that the holiday is not
about celebrating america for abolishing
slavery because it theoretically could
be about that if you had a holiday just
to celebrate emancipation then you could
say well yeah it's about how great
america is for abolishing slavery but
that's not what it's about did you
google juneteenth on juneteenth i did i
googled juneteenth and there was a a new
doodle or a new animation on google
there was all sorts of african flags
the kind of african black nationalist
flag the red and the green and the black
and it was there and those were all the
colors that you saw on the image search
on the page itself
wasn't a lot of american flags
it wasn't
why why is it that juneteenth
was pushed by the libs
some conservatives acquiesced to it but
it's not like this was a movement that
came out of the conservative side of the
aisle or the republican party it was
pushed by the libs and the libs are the
ones that celebrate it why because the
point of the holiday is to
say that america is all about slavery
not only was not unique to america
but
it's not not even particularly
distinctive
to him
every
i don't need to tell you this i've said
it many times but every country in the
history of the world has had slavery at
some point many countries still do what
makes the west unique is that
we abolished slavery slavery still
exists in africa it still exists in asia
still exists in certain indigenous
cultures
and yet
we
the the left in this country which hates
america tries to make the whole
tries to make slavery the entire
american story so i just think it's a
bad idea it's also historically a sort
of dumb day to celebrate the end of
slavery because it doesn't mark the end
of slavery slavery you could say slavery
ends with the emancipation proclamation
that happened before juneteenth long
before juneteenth you could say slavery
really officially ends with the passage
of the 13th amendment that happens after
long after juneteenth juneteenth is just
the day that the mail got to parts of
texas to tell the slaves that they had
been freed prior
it has been
in some parts of texas
a local tradition dating back
sometime some
in a lot of the
estate uh decades but you could say in
parts even earlier than that
but the only reason it's a federal
holiday now
is to dunk on america and make america
seem worse and more evil and say that
america's best days are going to be
ahead of us in the past was awful and
we're a enslaving terrible country uh so
i get it i know conservatives want to
enjoy juneteenth but
it's not there the the
the argue
as i've said i get the argument for
juneteenth because
black people have a unique position in
america in that black people
the ancestors of black people were not
people who chose to come here they were
in large part brought here involuntarily
and i am not one of those conservatives
who says that
you know well that was then this is now
forget about the past let's only focus
on the present and the future there
might be some practical wisdom to that
but also history matters i get it
is there any more conservative point of
view than to observe that history and
tradition and culture and the link
between the generations actually matters
no of course all those things do matter
but
the point of emancipation the point of
the 13th amendment the point of
the
reconstruction era is to say black
people are americans now we have settled
that question and so your independence
day is the same independence day as the
white people it's the same independence
day as everyone else in america it's
july 4th that's the day we're going to
celebrate by creating a separate
independence day which is what
juneteenth is the law creating june says
it's the juneteenth national
independence day
is to say there's a separate
independence day for black people the
black people are not really americans
we're not all just americans there's
actually a big distinction and we're
never going to come together and we're
never going to be a real country
that's what that's what the left wants
it for and that's a bad idea it's not a
good idea so it's a bad holiday
i'm i much prefer june 20th and june
21st and june 2nd speaking of slavery
and the legacy of slavery ibram x kendi
one of the most successful hustlers
huckster con artists in america who's
really enriched himself on on white
guilt and uh
liberal prattling on about about
slavery and legacy of slavery and race
politics
ibram kennedy says that the fight
to free the slaves is being reenacted
today in the fight
to take away your ar-15s
i know you have a six-year-old daughter
so i wonder how are you going to teach
her what this holiday is
well i'm actually going to teach her
that it's freedom day
and
that throughout this nation's history
there's been two perspectives on freedom
really two fights for freedom uh
enslaved people were fighting for
freedom from
slavery and enslavers were we're
fighting for the freedom to enslave and
in many ways that sort of contrast still
exist today they're people who are
fighting for freedom from assault rifles
freedom from poverty freedom from
exploitation and there are others who
are fighting for freedom to exploit
freedom to have guns freedom to maintain
inequality so i i really want to get her
to understand that there are multiple
kinds of freedom
and she should be fighting for and
joining with those who are fighting for
freedom from
something like slavery
as with almost everything ibram candy
says
this is a giant dumb point
a dumb stupid point with a little kernel
of a smart point hidden in there
so the comparison between taking away
people's guns and freeing the slaves is
not only a silly and absurd comparison
but it's
it they're really sort of opposite
points
to have a gun
the whole reason to have a gun right
there in the second amendment
is to protect yourself it is to give
yourself some independence so that you
are not
uh
easily enslaved and controlled
that's that's not to go hunting it's not
to go shooting clay pigeons it's to
protect yourself it's to defend
your freedom even even in that
traditional understanding of freedom
but the this smart point
hidden inside all of kennedy's stupid
demagoguery
is that today the way we talk about
freedom
is very relativistic
the way we talk about freedom
is
kind of a zero-sum game
when some people get freedom other
people lose freedom
and and so freedom is not
reasonable
it's not logical it's not it's not tied
to anything in objective reality it's
just about all different competing
interests the interests between the
slavers and the enslaved between the
people who want guns and the people who
don't want guns the people who want i
don't know want drugs and the people who
don't want drugs on the streets that's
that's the way that we do talk about
freedom today it's a stupid view of
freedom though
though it is how we talk about it the
freedom of the transgender man i'm sorry
transgender woman to use the women's
bathroom even though he's a dude the
freedom of the transgender man
woman to swim on the girl's swim team
even though he's a dude
necessarily infringes on the freedom of
the women to have their own bathrooms
and locker rooms where they can change
and don't need to have men expose their
genitals to them
or infringes on the freedom of women to
have their own swim teams and swimming
leagues where they can win their own
trophies and win their own scholarships
and not constantly be beaten by men
if there is
if freedom can describe all of those
things then yes those freedoms are in
conflict but that's why there is no such
thing as a freedom
[Music]
to transgenderism as a right to
transgenderism
the lib understanding of freedom as
being able to do whatever you want to do
and just follow your own desires is
just a false one and you're especially
seeing this here and abram kennedy is
accidentally proving it to you
there's then the conservative
understanding of freedom which is that
freedom
is not sinning
freedom is doing good freedom is doing
what you're supposed to do the man who
sins is a slave to sin
that liberty i've talked about this on
the show many times that liberty is not
licentiousness that you don't you don't
have a right to do something that is
unreasonable and not to your benefit as
edmund burke says you don't have a right
to pretend to be a woman and go into the
women's bathroom you can't because it
doesn't make any sense because it's not
true because you're not a woman
that's why you can't have a right to
that even if some crazy activist with
all sorts of crazy colored hair and lots
of
lots of piercings or whatever and
mutilated body parts says i have a right
to this well no you're just that's just
a thing you're saying
so you can say you have a right to but
why do you have a right to that
why you there's no explanation but a
right that is inexplicable a right that
can't have some grounding in objective
reality in say the natural law is no
right at all
that's no so if we're going to if we're
going to talk about real freedom we're
going to talk about real rights we've
got to ground it in reality and that
means we need to
discard
probably 90 percent of these supposed
rights that have cropped up in recent
years and that continue to crop up every
day just like we need to discard 99
of the fake pronouns that have cropped
up in recent years
you can call yourself by those pronouns
yesterday we played a clip of a woman
who calls herself bun refers to her
pronouns as bun bun self bun bun self
and fair self and all sorts of like just
completely made up words
you can say that those are pronouns but
they're not actually pronouns because
pronouns are limited and they
they have something to do with objective
reality i'm glad you like that clip now
hold on
ring the bell you know please subscribe
like do all that subscribe on apple
podcast leave a five-star review and
then copy this url right now wherever
you are on your app anything copy that
url
got it now text it
to three of your best friends
i
i am concerned as a philanthropist i
have heard that there are actually still
some people
who do not listen to or watch the
michael knowles show and this is very
sad these people are deprived you can
change that right now you've got it in
your power
text it email it to your friends your
relatives do an act of kindness and
charity today we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]